Speaker 1: There was a march for life, and
this is an anti-abortion event. Former NFL
coach Tony Dungy, who I didn't realize was a
sort of right wing extremist. He spoke at the
March for Life and he drew a parallel between
NFL football player DeMar Hamlin's cardiac
arrest and abortion. What is the connection?
I sure as hell don't know. But let's see if
we can understand it as Tony Dungy explains it.
Speaker 2: Well, those prayers were answered.
Demarr is recovering now. He's home.
He's been released from the hospital.
But what's the lesson in there? You know,
an unbelievable thing happened that night.
A professional football game with millions of
dollars of ticket money and advertising money
on the line. That game was canceled. Why? Because
a life was at stake. Huh? And people wanted to
see that life saved. Even people who aren't
necessarily religious got together and called
on God. Well, that should be encouraging to us
because that's exactly why we're here today.
Wait a second. Because every day in
this country, innocent lives are at
stake. The only difference is they don't
belong to a famous athlete and they're
not seen on national TV. Huh. But those
lives are still important to God and in
God's eyes.
Speaker 1:
So I did not realize that Tony Dungy had these
views. And there are a couple important things
I think to mention here. You can be individually
pro-life or pro-choice, you know, for abortion,
against abortion in some cases or not, whatever.
Right. I mean, it is your choice when we say
pro-choice. I'm certainly not saying pro-choice
means everyone must be in favor of abortion, being
safe, available and legal. I'm saying it should be
everyone's choice if you or Tony Dungy or whoever.
Is opposed to abortion. Then I don't think anyone
should force you or a mother or whoever to have an
abortion. That's what I when I say choice, I mean
choice on both sides. But when they liken abortion
to the Damar Hamlin situation, which by the way,
it's such a stretch, it doesn't even make any
sense whatsoever. You were starting to go over
into this extremely authoritarian perspective,
which is it's no one's. Well, it's Tony Dungy
choice that no one else would be able to decide
for themselves what the right decision is. There
are people who can choose not to get an abortion
for whatever reason they want. That's part of
the choice. But they want to take choice away
from everybody. They want to take bodily autonomy
away from women and families in consultation with
whoever they want to consult with. If you as a
pregnant woman. Want to consult with your clergy
about what you should do. That's your choice.
And that's fine. That's part of the choice we're
talking about. But to say that the woman should
not even have on the table the choice to say,
Well, what's right for me is an abortion. That
is where these people go completely haywire. And,
by the way, against their own principles of keep
government out of stuff to the extent that we can.
One other thing, the stick to sports crowd is
very silent. Very, very silent. The shut up and
dribble LeBron. People are very, very quiet when
it comes to someone like Tony Dungy expressing
an anti-abortion view, which is just part,
of course, of that hypocrisy that they have.